Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie. Marvel just revealed
what's going on with our Iron Man
armor Wars movie during Marvel Phase 6.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a bunch of stuff
they're bringing back.
So if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Just starting with the big stuff.
First they did confirmed that Armor Wars
is now going to be a movie in Marvel
Phase six instead of a Disney Plus series.
That's why they kept delaying it.
They haven't been talking about it
in a long time.
It's mostly because of the budget.
It's the first Marvel series
that's actually gone upstream that way
with a lot of the Marvel Phase four Disney
Plus series that we've gotten.
Having started life as movies
that they commissioned writers
to develop a long time ago, and they just
later decided to turn into series
I, I made Macaroni.
The Swan song Moon Knight in the Hawkeye
series are good examples of that,
like they started as movies
that Marvel commissioned a long time ago,
and they kind of sat on a shelf
and they decided they wouldn't
be strong enough to be a movie compared
to the other movies that they did.
So they just wound up turning them
into series.
The reason Armor Wars turned into a movie
is mostly because of budget,
because Marvel typically caps
the budget of their Disney
Plus series at about $150 million.
That's why they're usually only six
episodes or nine episodes.
But the six episode series are always
a little bit longer, like 45 minutes
per episode compared to like 30 minutes
per episode.
For the nine episode series,
they decided they needed
way more than the typical $150 million
to do all the Iron Man armor
that they want to do during the movie
because the Armor Wars
movie would largely have to be special
effects start to finish.
If they done it as a series,
they'd have to do like five episodes
of them walking and talking around
and then one episode with them wearing
some armors with a couple of the armors.
So wouldn't have felt very satisfying
what people would have
normally expected from an Iron Man Armor
War series like Where is this armory?
Why are they all going crazy?
They are doing a version of
the original comics story of Armor wars.
The only difference is that Iron
Man was still around when that happened,
and they already did
part of the plot of that armor wars
for the Iron Man two movie
with the Justin Hammer storyline.
In the comic version,
Justin Hammer hires a bunch of people
to steal Iron Man's technology
and then runs the mask.
Basically,
what you saw during Iron Man two.
The minor change, though, is
that you have to imagine the end of Iron
Man three with all of his armor
showing up, piloted by Jarvis.
That was a little more
in the vein of Armor Wars,
where you have a bunch of his armor
suits going crazy.
But one of the other big differences
with this new version
that they're doing in Marvel
Phase six is that one of the main villains
will be Ultron, who will return, played
by James Spader himself, or at least he's
supposed to be played by James Spader.
This time.
They actually just brought Ultron back
as part of the big Disney Wish storyline
that they did.
All of
a sudden, this is where they keep
the room.
It's a weird opening line.
I think that
is. Seriously?
Yeah, I didn't do anything.
Oh, get out of my way.
That was where
all those Ant-Man scenes came from,
where he was joking about the bonus,
like they actually paid off.
The thing is, scene.
Look, before we start,
let me address the elephant in the room.
I heard a lot of chatter out there
asking why I didn't
shrink down to go in and
kill Thanos
in a really creative way to protect this,
first of all.
GROSS Certainly,
it's much more complicated than that.
Let me to explain.
If only we had big time Avengers
into the Thanos.
They did bring Ultron back for the
What If series as the Infinity.
Ultron, who gained all six
Infinity stones, turning himself
into a living Infinity gantlet,
embedding them in his chest.
We got some of the craziest scenes
in a marvel series or movie ever
Ultron versus the Watcher
punching him across the universes,
chomping down, destroying entire galaxies.
But that version of Ultron was played
by Ross Marchand, who you remember either
from The Walking Dead or as Red Skull
during Infinity War in Avengers Endgame.
That's why those characters
had a little bit different.
Like Ultron during What If sounded
a little bit different, and Red Skull
during Infinity War, Endgame sounded
just a little bit different.
He did a pretty good job of approximating
the performance of the original actors
for those characters,
but apparently
because they upgraded Armor Wars
to a movie,
they have a movie level budget.
They can pay James Spader
movie level money to come back.
The idea with Ultron returning,
though, is that when Vision destroyed
his final body at the end of Avengers
Age of Ultron, that Ultron.
But he didn't
truly destroy the Ultron A.I.
itself.
It just went dormant.
Also, the ideas of vision
is the fusion of Ultron A.I.
programing in Jarvis.
So there were always pieces of Ultron
original code inside Vision's programing.
And we saw during Wandavision
that the original vision was reactivated
by Tyler
Hayward and Sword as White Vision.
Scarlet Witch created hex vision
from her memories with her chaos magic.
He had all of Vision's memories
from before his death in Infinity War.
He reactivated all of those inside
White vision who then flew off
to stew on everything until armor wars
in the Vision Quest series.
They're also giving White Vision
a new wandavision spin off series
called Vision Quest
based on that comic book storyline
and the more recent vision storyline
where he created a family for himself.
They also used a little bit of that
for Wandavision, but not a ton of it.
But the basic idea is that white
vision is meant to be the original vision.
He's also basically stark tech.
That's
why he's supposed to return in armor wars.
He's basically
like Tony Stark's other child.
They might bring Justin Hammer Back
is another villain during the movie,
but I'm also expecting them to introduce
some other larger characters who weren't
in the original Armor Wars comics story,
but are Iron Man based villains.
The last armor
that we saw Iron Man wearing
during Avengers Endgame was his Mark 85.
Remember that His Infinity War armor
was his mark 50.
So the idea is that during the five year
time jump, he created 35
new armor suits
that we only saw one of on screen.
There are 34 that they just jumped over
and never showed us.
There wasn't concept art
that they released for his armory
that we were meant
to see during Infinity War.
But it sounds like they deleted that scene
early in the process
and just decided to skip it.
We don't need to explain
what happened to all those armors.
They'll cover that in some other movie.
And now we're getting that other movie.
They'll probably also introduce
some other prototype armors
that he would have worn
had he survived Avengers Endgame,
like newer experimental armor intact
that he designed but hadn't worn yet.
But the idea is that
during the five year time jump,
even though they made it seem like he'd
permanently retired
at least briefly, from The Avengers,
he continued to create new armors.
That's where the pepper Pops
armor came from.
Like he designed that while
he was designing these other 35 armors
until the events of Spider-Man
No Way Home with Dr.
Strange's two spells making everyone
forget Peter Parker was Spider-Man.
Technically, he'd actually
given Spider-Man controller access
to most of that tech with Edith.
But the second spell wiping
everyone's minds, making them forget
Peter Parker was Spider-Man,
also undid some of that stuff.
So in the new post, Spider-Man
No Way Home Timeline also posts
Loki with the multiverse
going crazy with everything spinning up
to Kang Dynasty and the Council of Kings.
The new back story
on Earth, at least, is the damage
control is now the tool of the government,
which is really under
the control of Thunderbolt
Ross, who's going to become the President
of the United States, and Val,
a lot of shadier people in there co-opting
all this stark tech
like you saw during Spider-Man,
no way home with them
taking control of a lot of stark tech.
So don't be surprised if damage control
winds up being one of the villains
during the Armor Wars series.
In fact, during the original comic book
Armor Wars, the U.S.
government actually uses some stolen
stark tech to create their own armor
suit, iron monger styled
like a real big one called Firepower,
which Iron Man winds up having to destroy.
So you can see how Thunderbolt,
Ross and valor
eventually lead to a lot of this bad stuff
happening during armor wars.
In the same way that sword
kind of became backdoor villains
during the Wandavision series.
All these people
within those organizations,
they kind of got into this during the Ms..
Marvel series.
Damage control was using the stark tech
drones, the Edith The drones.
They just repainted them
to look a little bit different,
but they were meant to be the same drones
going after regular citizens
instead of just regular criminals.
Basically,
The idea is that during Marvel Phase five
Thunderbolt, Ross eventually becomes
President of the United States.
Val is now in charge of the CIA in
they're using it to turn the United States
into something more akin to a police state
in paying off that line from Avengers
Age of Ultron, where Iron Man
said, I would like to wrap that world
in a suit of armor.
The whole idea that Iron Man
had become paranoid and he wanted to over
protect the world at the cost
of everyone's personal freedoms.
In our thunderbolt,
Ross and Val are just actually doing that.
So they do bring Justin Hammer back
during the Armor Wars series.
They can just say that he's
actually working for Thunderbolt,
Ross and Val, and things start to go crazy
with the armors going out of control,
Ultron being released again.
There are reports that Robert Downey
Jr is supposed to come back
as a version of Iron Man,
but not as the original 616 Iron
Man that died during Avengers Endgame.
The rumor is that he's actually going
to be a version of that 838 universe
Iron Man, the alternate superior
Iron Man that we didn't see during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
There were all those
Tom Cruise rumors at the time,
but now the report is
they're just going to use Robert Downey
Jr as a version of that alternate
Iron Man in different movies.
But I don't know which movie
they're going to bring him back in
in when he comes back.
The whole idea is that
they'll just be looking for revenge
for the death of the Illuminati.
So to be Robert Downey
Jr playing a twist on Iron Man
in that he's seeking revenge
against our normal Avengers characters,
even though technically
Scarlet Witch is the one to blame
for the death of all those Illuminati.
The Armor War series is supposed to come
after Avengers Kang Dynasty.
It sounds like the way
they're going to plot this out
is that they're going to do things
like Infinity War
and then Ant-Man and the WASP.
If you remember, Amon and the WASP
came out right after the snap,
but they just said that most of the movie
took place before the events of the snap,
and they did the snap
during one of the Post-Credits scenes
where the timeline caught up.
Right now, I'm assuming most of the movies
in the Disney Plus series
that come between Avengers
five and Avengers six will be like that.
Like they'll have a post-credits scene
where
the timeline catches up in all of reality,
just collapses around them.
But if you've any of the questions
about what's going on with Robert Downey
Jr coming back as a version of Iron Man
or the Armor Wars movie,
just write them below in the comments.
Everyone click here for my Deadpool
3 teaser video
and click here for my Mandalorian Season
three Episode four Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.